at least fighting he's pushing through
he's you know working to get better
Buffalo Bills safety Demar Hamlin
suffered a cardiac arrest and collapsed
Monday night it happened when the
athlete made a tackle during the first
quarter against the Bengals in
Cincinnati what we saw was a a player
who had a direct impact to the middle of
their chest and this is what we consider
blunt trauma now a family spokesperson
is sharing an update on the 24 year old
athlete who's hospitalized and in
critical condition there's still a lot
that fits Up in the Air Jordan Rooney a
friend of Demars opened up to ET on
Tuesday about the moment the NFL pro
collapsed on the field I mean it was
tough like just seeing everyone's
reactions
it was it was a little scary I mean
because you know the hit didn't look bad
but then you saw everyone's reactions
you're like what are we missing like
what's going on Demar was down for at
least 15 minutes paramedics administered
CPR while players from both teams
gathered around many broke down in tears
Demar was taken off the field in an
ambulance and the game was suspended it
looks like the mechanism of arrest in um
Demar Hanlon was a direct impact to the
center of his chest which unfortunately
happened at a perfect time when his
heart was trying to relax and that is
what led to the son of cardiac arrest
the Buffalo Bills later confirmed in a
statement that Demar suffered a cardiac
arrest his heartbeat was restored on the
field and he was transferred to the
University of Cincinnati Medical Center
for further testing and treatment where
he is currently sedated and listed in
critical condition the family has been
you know incredibly thankful because for
them it's it's just it's a really tough
moment so to have so many people unite
around this challenging time it makes a
difference demar's family was at the
game and Jordan said they're staying
strong these parents like they're
Fighters I mean they are like it's one
of the best support systems that anyone
can have and honestly it shows why Demar
is so strong-willed and caring it's just
a testament to who they are they
obviously are nervous it's a little
scary for them
um but they're optimistic on Tuesday the
family released a statement on Twitter
thanking fans for their love and support
writing that they are deeply moved by
the prayers kind words and donations
since the incident fans have poured
millions of dollars into a charity that
Demar started in 2020. shortly before he
was picked in the sixth round of the
2021 NFL Draft when you decide to
GoFundMe in 2020 I don't think he ever
would have expected there would be close
to 4 million dollars in that account he
likes being a professional athlete
because it gives him the platform and
influence to create social change like
that is who Demar is he has these big
ideas of ways he wants to help kids but
you know we were talking 10 to 30k
budgets before the GoFundMe page
initially set a 2 500 goal but has since
surpassed three million dollars Demar
explained he created his foundation as a
way to pay it forward quote as I embark
on my journey to the NFL I will never
forget where I come from and I am
committed to using my platform to
positively impact the community that
raised me
foreign
[Music]